[Musik]
möchte euch recht herzlich begrüßen
mein name ist leutnant jürgen beyer ich
bin einsatz pilot hier bei uns in der
bewaffneten mehrzweckhubschrauber
staffel in langen leben am hof ski in
niederösterreich
was würden wir uns heute anschauen wie
wir euch heute unser luftfahrzeug zeigen
die 58 b des österreichischen
bundesheeres dieses luftfahrzeug ist
seit mittlerweile 1976 im dienst und wir
sind der einzige bewaffnete hubschrauber
seit anbeginn sozusagen nur sehen wir
hier die 58 b ist ein leichter
verbindungs und mehrzweckhubschrauber
der eben dazu benutzt wird auf der einen
seite mit der bewaffnung
luftraumsicherung operationen
durchzuführen
wir sind aber auch mit
spezialeinsatzkräften wieder im jahr
commander unterwegs wo dann hinten die
türen ausgebaut werden und zum beispiel
zwei scharfschützen raus wirken können
wir sind aber auch bei tag und bei nacht
unterwegs auch in urbanen gebieten mit
spezialkräften wo wir dann anlandungen
auch auf häuserdächer wochen oder die
sogenannte weg hinter dicken durchführen
das heißt wir machen fahrzeug
anhaltungen aus der luft und holt dann
bedrohe gefährder aus den fahrzeugen
raus also dass wochen die
spezialeinsatzkräfte nicht mehr wir ja
wir haben auch einen 4 port unten dran
bei manchen maschinen wo wir dann mit
den luftbildern auch das fliegende auge
darstellen um dem den luftraum oder im
dem boden von oben beobachten können
wir machen ein fluch bilder das heißt
wir haben dann einen fotografen hinteren
sitzen und wo wir dann eine spezial tür
haben die dann geöffnet werden kann und
wo wir luft bilder anfertigen die dann
für die jeweiligen kunden zur verfügung
gestellt werden
ja unser hauptaufgabe besteht aber auch
in der schulung von anderen truppen
körpern wie man mit dem hubschrauber
interagiert wie eben der check der
forward er controller wie auch heißt mit
dem hubschrauber agieren kann und wir
den hubschrauber zu sich holt und ins
ziel bringt wie gesagt da sitzt er heute
schon da ist die gatling gun aufmontiert
so direkt dann aber später noch mehr
sagen werde
ich fange jetzt einfach an bedeutet dass
man rundgang machen die daily inspection
wie wir sagen die jeder pilot vor flug
antritt noch einmal machen was für
disney mit wir machen jetzt so wie es
immer jeden tag mache einen rundgang um
den hubschrauber und schauen wir noch
mal neuralgische punkte an ob er noch
alles passt passt kommt einfach mit
für das fangen wir einfach vorne an und
wir bewegen uns dann sozusagen im
uhrzeigersinn um den hubschrauber herum
der hammer hier unser sogenanntes peter
rohr mit dem wird der luftdruck
abgenommen und den braucht man ganz
einfach für verschiedenste instrumente
vor allem fünf messer das heißt da wird
einfach die geschwindigkeit messen
doch vorne haben wir noch ein altes
relikt aus der zeit wo wir die
grenzüberwachung fürs bundesministerium
für inneres chrome sein
das ist einfach antenne für polizeifunk
gewesen dann eine der meisten fragen die
wirkstatt bekommen wenn wir irgendwo mit
den luftfahrzeugen zum beispiel am
heldenplatz gestanden sein
die meisten leute gefragt für was diese
zwei sachen zuständig sein
das wort gab es sogar schon mal eine
frage diesbezüglich im internet gegeben
das sind sogenannte hebel katar oder war
ja protection system das heißt wenn wir
wie seiner recht oft im tiefflug
unterwegs und sollten wir mal dass
karten studium nicht richtig gemacht
haben und eine leitung kommt uns
entgegen dann breit diese leitung hier
oben ob dort darunter seien schon keine
wie säge szene santoro eingeschossen das
heißt es sprengt dann weg und das kabel
wird nach oben hin weg geführt und sei
gekappt werden genauso enten dadurch
dass der hubschrauber sei jetzt
natürlich sagt das ist ja viel zu kurz
für die kufen
dadurch dass wir im vorwärts flug sind
verschwinden ja dann die kurven darunter
und das wird sich ausgehen dass eben
dort rufen auch ohne schaden davon
kommen wurde schon einmal getestet gehe
von einem unserer staffel mitglieder
nach gott sei dank ist nichts passiert
kann es ganz ganz dünnes telefonkabel
würde darüber sehen und doch sind das
die wirklich funktionieren und dass es
aufgeschnitten worden ist ja wenn man
weiter gehen
dann schaue immer immer an den rumpf
verformungen da wird man sehen natürlich
das gerät ist schon ein bisschen in die
jahre gekommen
es gibt schon über kleine dellen aber
die sind nicht relevant seien auch keine
tragenden konstruktionsteile da ja darf
der seite haben wir dann das portal zum
staudruck daher den statischen druck der
hier abgenommen wird und auch mal auf
der anderen seite wie gesagt das ist für
meine instrumente im cockpit zuständig
da wird ganz einfach mit den
druckunterschied zum beispiel die höhe
dann raus messen beziehungsweise ob ich
steige oder sind für das vario meter
passt hier schreiben ganz einfach an ob
die tür
ob das passt optisch an ihren orten und
sein und dann steige ich eigentlich
schon ein und schaue mir ins cockpit ins
innere däninnen check mache stark es
gern wenn man sie doch rein setzt dann
sehen wir hier die instrumentierung von
einem hubschrauber das ist natürlich
noch die generation von hubschrauber das
heißt wir haben da wenig fernseher unter
anführungszeichen bildschirme das
einzige was wir da haben ist unser gps
monitor
ansonsten haben wir doch kein glas
cockpit ist anno es nur sozusagen wie
wir sagen er uhren bei uns gehen
da haben wir eben die ganzen flug
überwachungsinstrumente das heißt
deutschland
triberg ob alles passt und hier haben
wir fürs navigieren und da
anführungszeichen ist höhenmesser dann
aber doch einen anführungszeichen
schnaps kompass
und da jetzt dadurch dass wir heute
schießen fliegen haben wir da was ganz
spezielles was nur bei uns im
hubschrauber vorkommt da haben wir
unsere visiereinrichtung das geht über
ein spiegel wird wir von hinten ein
fadenkreuz eingespielt und die kann so
auf mein ziel grob investieren wenn es
dann zu waffen kommen würden erklären
jede vierte patrone ist bei uns eine
leuchtspur mit terrakotta und genau ins
ziel rein
ja das war es eigentlich erinnern im
cockpit räumen und dann schauen wir
weiter
der machbarkeit wenn man hier in der
bewegung sind brauche ich die türe
hinten wie gesagt wie ich zuerst erklärt
habe die kann man ganz einfach
rausnehmen und dann kann hinten einen
scharfschützen zum beispiel platz nehmen
und dann von draußen dringen nach außen
wirken wenn es dann blickte reinwerfen
wird da hat es nämlich auch gleich
hinten den waffenträger der wirt tor
eingebaut einfach wo normalerweise
sitzplätze an passt jetzt steigen marina
vom hubschrauber
da haben wir da vorne so kleine
öffnungen so kleine fenster dort kann
ich meine checks machen sollte doch
etwas repariert werden müssen kann man
die genannten die gesamte kauling mit
ganz wenigen schraubenzieher trägern
sozusagen unternehmen und dann kann die
technik darauf wirken dort drinnen sind
wir das hydraulik compartment das heißt
unsere steuer gerne sind einfach
hydraulik verstärkt sonst würde das sehr
viel kraft kosten und so kann man recht
fein den hubschrauber steuern dort
einfach rein
doch einmal sogenannte pops wird würden
wir anzeigen wenn die hydraulik system
verstopft ist und vorne schauen und
darauf dass die steuer stangen oder die
servo stangen dass die nicht verschmutzt
sein und leichtgängig gehen sollten ja
und wieder zu machen nächster deckel
da sehen wir jetzt dass haupt getriebe
das ist so grauer größerer warschau
sorgen und ist sozusagen antriebsstrang
dahinter man das triebwerk und kommt
dann über die kurze welle die man drei
schafften es haupt getriebe der firma
circa vom getriebe weggang mit circa 33
1000 umdrehungen war man in triberg ganz
untersetzungsgetriebe und sekunde mit
6000 umdrehungen in mainhardt getriebe
und dann gehts da wird über ein
planetengetriebe 90 grad um gewandert
und geht dann rauf auf mein haupt roth
der mast und meine art rotorblätter und
kommt dann mit ca 356 umdrehungen pro
minute am haupt total gedreht sei aber
sänger dort der haupt druck der mast ist
kommt nicht unbedingt die gäste aber für
uns ausreichend und die zwei stangen
wurden in besser an die sandte steuer
stangen mit den wird über die damals
scheibe einfach oben der haupt roter
kopf angesteuert und jetzt hat meine
zyklische und meine kollektive steuerung
es werden dann von der anderen seite
nachsehen wo sie dann komplett auf
kraxeln sozusagen und mit den haupt
roter kopf und anschauen was hier wie
schon angesprochen habe befindet sich im
unser triebwerk das ist ein ellison c250
und hat ca 400 ps
ja
was erst recht für schläuche natürlich
wird von der technik vorher hubschrauber
genauestens durchgeschaut der pilot
macht dann nur mehr die deckel nach von
schadet sich noch irgendetwas verändert
hat ob irgendwelche außergewöhnlichen
flüssigkeitsstände am boden sind ja
eigentlich drüber über das triebwerk was
man das st hier ist der lufteinlass das
heißt dort kommt die luft rein wird hier
komprimiert kommt dann hinten in die
brennkammer dort wird dann der crash
treibstoff eingespritzt und treibt mir
sozusagen meine arbeit turbine an und
die verdichter turbine die man dann also
wieder vor einem verdichter antreibt ja
und die luft schon geht dann geht dann
doch aus und über den abgas strahlte
werden die abgase wieder nach außen
geleitet
was natürlich auch anschauen es immer
das kufen lande gestellt das heißt er
muss ja bisher in die knie gehen und die
schauer optionen welche verformungen auf
meinen kufen rohre sahen oder auch
verformungen herunter auf der unterseite
von rom
hier haben wir unsere unseren dank den
gefühlen wir immer mit 350 pfund
hineingehen würden 450 punkt es ist ganz
einfach aus einsatztaktischen gründen
wir wissen nicht wie viele leute dass
man mitnehmen und können dann noch mehr
rein danken oder theoretisch wäre sogar
die möglichkeit dass wir was noch n
tanken gesetz mit 450 pfund kommen wir
circa zwei stunden 50 aus wir brauchen
also fast 150 punkte in der stunde des
st ein skipper sowas herum brauchen wir
in der stunde an kerosin oder chat 1
widersteht
wenn man dort dann weiter nach hinten
geht schaue ich mir eigentlich dann nur
die beleuchtung an den rumpf der kammer
zum zum heck ausleger wie wir nennen da
mal eben die stabilisierungs flossen da
wird einfach geschaut und nicht
irgendwelche markanten stellen oder was
fahren was wir haben noch den spuren
hinten der uns einfach davor schützt
sollte der hubschrauber mal bis knapp am
boom kommen dass nicht unbedingt gleich
dahinter dann in den boden ein pferd
weil wir nehmen die hubschrauber auch
zur schulung natürlich und da kann es
passieren dass man manchmal bisher und
bund kommt ja da hinten haben neben dem
headquarter dieses ach da kommt über die
hecke auf der welle kommt mit 6000
umdrehungen nase vorn gehabt haben
kriegen wir die umdrehungen wird dann
auch um 90 grad wieder umgelenkt und wir
kommen damit ca 2550 umdrehungen auf den
kleinen hektar dieses auch besonderheit
eben wir sind jeweils zwei blätter und
hektar wir haben eine gemeinsame ein
gemeinsames schlag gelingt ja
deutschland einfach auf den zustand der
rotorblätter ich schaue mal hier meine
steuer stangen oder patch links an und
wenn man dort kann man sehen wie sich
die blätter verstellen dass woche fuhren
mit der pedale und je nachdem ich den
anstellwinkel verträge mehr oder weniger
schub und die kam den hubschrauber um
die hochachse drehen passt
vom 2 hier kommen wir jetzt auf die
andere seite vom triebwerk doch in
hannover auf und schauen ob alles passt
im großen und ganzen hier man verstehe
mutter mit dem wird eigentlich
angesteuert wie viel treibstoff
eingespritzt wird ja dann wenn man
gerade dort sind jetzt kommt der aktuell
auf den hubschrauber hinaufklettern der
kandidatin waffenträger benutzen
dann wird hier auf klettert und dann
schau mal die ganze hubschrauber
plattform von herr oben an und
kontrolliert auch noch mein haupt roter
system durchschaut einfach die blätter
entlang wo wir irgendwo wie der
verformungen feststelle auch auf der
blattunterseite und darum haben wir ein
ganz ganz wichtiges teil die heißt
chestnut weil das lebensumfeld piloten
dranhängt mit dieser mutter wir
eigentlich us zu antworten und wird
sozusagen der kraftschluss hergestellt
ja immer wieder meine lieblings an
tormann hat man ein blick ein bisserl
wieder auf die hydraulik ob man da
irgendwelche unstimmigkeiten sid und
wenn nicht von der wieder runter das
einfach
ja herr unten angekommen sind wir unser
spezielles teil eben unser mgm 134 auch
gatling genannt so es sind ja wort gibt
schon seit 1860 in unserer form wie sie
wiedersehen weil es elektrisch
angetrieben ist seit 1970 wird es
eingesetzt
mit sagte captain ist sechs häufig und
wird durch eine elektrische motor
angetrieben wir verwenden diese waffe
eben für luft- boden- ziele und auch
luft luft ziele
das heißt wir fliegen dann wird auch
trainiert in ein stück voraus fliegt
eine pc 6 in den schlafsack wie es an
hinten traf der schlepp sagt wir davor
1000 meter ausgefahren und wir bekämpfen
dann sozusagen ein schlafsack und der
zeigt dann die treffen ob man das
imaginäre luftfahrzeug getroffen hätte
oder nicht bodenzielen eigene schießbahn
um einen einsteig wo verschiedene ziele
aufbaut sind und diese werden dann
bekämpft bei tag und bei nacht
zugang gibt sonst eigentlich nicht mehr
viel zu sagen
sie hat ca 2 bis 4 der ausschuss in der
minute keinen job gefeiert werden ist
nicht circa sondern wir haben zwei
stellungen das eine ist wenn man den
trigger nur halb durchzieht haben 2000
schuss hinter minute wenn info
durchzieht 4000 schuss wird jetzt aber
modifiziert wir können dann ein motor
ein
und dann gibt es nur mit 3000 schuss in
der minute
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das war's im prinzip von unserem
rundgang um 258 b wird zurück ganz
besonderes für mich jetzt mit und zeigt
euch wie ein hubschrauber fliegt
funktioniert und gestartet wird kommt
mit hubschrauber läuft jetzt auf 100
prozent
wenn wir jetzt abheben wollen muss ich
hier den kollektiv einfach anheben
dadurch erhöht sich der anstellwinkel
und darum sauber geht nach oben wenn ich
jetzt nach rechts wie zum beispiel muss
ich den stick der dort sich meine füße
angeordnet ist nach rechts betätigen und
der hubschrauber fliegt langsam nach
rechts
jetzt wenn ich am stand nicht drehen wir
das um die hochachse muss sich einfach
ins linke pedal in eintreten kann sagte
und der hubschrauber fängt sich an über
links zu drehen
da merkt man jetzt dass der wind
deutschen start gehen will ich jetzt mit
dem schauer nach vorschlägen muss sich
den stick nach vor geben nicht auf und
befreie
den links nach links und rechts nach
rechts
wenn ich jetzt den hubschrauber absetzen
will muss sich wieder an collective oder
pitch demnach um den geben und der
hubschrauber bewegt sich auch nachdem
das war es jetzt von meiner seiten mit
dem kurzen rundgang um die uhr 58
die einweisung und zuschauer wie
sollten sie interesse haben die chance
auf karriere.at arbeit drin zu sein
quelle
[Musik]